hace un año el asesinato de George Floyd
desató Las mayores protestas
antirracistas y contra la brutalidad
policial en décadas alrededor del
planeta la víspera del aniversario de su
muerte cientos de personas salieron a
recordarlo
la policía ha causado tanto dolor para
tantas familias y un año después No
deberíamos estar aquí suplicando cambios
en la legislación esta Debería ser la
última de nuestras preocupaciones
mientras enterramos a nuestros seres
queridos
la sentencia contra la ex policía Derek
exobing culpable de asesinato en segundo
y tercer grado y de homicidio en segundo
grado fue celebrada como histórica a
raíz del dictamen el presidente
estadounidense condenó el racismo
sistémico que mancha el país ahora
vaiden insiste en la necesidad de
aprobar el proyecto de ley justicia para
George Floyd
la legislación incluye la prohibición de
técnicas de inmovilización como la de
ahogamiento con la que el ex policía
blanco derecho
estadounidense de 46 años y un registro
de agresiones policiales la cámara de
representantes de mayoría demócrata
aprobó la legislación a principios de
marzo pero ahora está en punto muerto en
el senado
siglos de racismo sistémico y excesos
policiales y no devolverá a George Floyd
briona Taylor digan su nombre Briana
Taylor
very ni de incontables
pero supondrá un enorme paso adelante
para frenar la violencia el sufrimiento
y comenzar a construir un mejor Estados
Unidos
el nombre de George Floyd ha quedado
grabado en la historia ahora la lucha
del movimiento Black lives matter Es que
la cambie